so three credit cards a mortgage and a
car loan that's like the perfect mates
like five they have like five trade
lines and that's it so if you have eight
credit cards to car loan to you know now
they're like something's going all those
getting loaded up with I'm sorry I'm
sorry I have to interrupt this we have
to put this on here hey you're live on
YouTube right now you're live
you're live with Matt Cox on YouTube
tell Matt Cox where you are right now
are you in be cray
[Music]
we got a podcast coming up with the
Emperor of the universe
Frank Amedeo so tell me what's it like
in there right now
yeah
we're gonna pick you up we're gonna make
a documentary
so tell me what is it like right now
inside Coleman federal prison during
this pandemic plague that we're dealing
with what's the worst thing about being
in there during this pandemic what's the
worst thing you've seen
has anybody has anybody in Coleman
that's in there locked up with you been
tested positive for coronavirus come on
tell me tell me well what's that let's
go on with the shoe why is the shoe
no they're not let him out we have open
we have open beds all over you're in the
fishbowl and what's going on with your
roommate John John he thought it was a
sandal
hey you're nowhere near Ricky tees
LeBron is doing yoga is LeBron doing a
lot of yoga in there with you what's he
doing right now
hey have you read have you read the
Matthew Cox story called it's insanity
about can you can you wave down the
Emporer real quick get him over there
summon the emperor on impulse like that
[Music]
so what are the security guards the
prison guards treating you any
differently like what's going on there
give me you know paint a picture for me
[Music]
we'll bring a whole crew people to
donate some money in the comments to the
commissary you're talking to you're
talking to a couple hundred people right
now on the internet right now if you
want if there was one thing you wanted
to communicate to the outside world if
there was one thing you wanted to
communicate to the outside world right
now about what you're dealing with what
would you want to let them know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
see ya wouldn't wanna be a see going to
a halfway house I don't know who knows
okay
that was [ __ ] crazy that I just
recently found out he was in prison
he's knew how not the first time but did
he go obviously he's been in there for
over ten years previously for a cocaine
charge I know this was a new charge this
was not he missed the 90s he was in
prison in the like throughout the entire
90s and then he just recently went back
for some other charge so he's only in
there for I think a year and a half or
two years right okay huh but what are
the chances he's right where you were
live I mean that's crazy what you know a
set that the phones are like this so
you're you're sitting there talking on
the phone the other guys right here I
mean there's a phone booth this wide
yeah and there's stacks beside so you've
got this mushroom with a phone so the
other guy's right next to you and his
phone so you're all basically shoulders
shoulder yeah talking I mean that's how
it is in the end of the the cells are
about double the size is this right here
no and I've been double the size this
about to here so they're like six foot
by maybe 10 feet maybe 11 feet with the
bunk beds in there so when you're County
I mean you're literally you guys are
standing in there you're a foot away
from you're always a foot or two foot
away from it everybody all the time so
if it gets in there there yeah you
always say that that every time if one
guy started coughing yeah within three
days you could lay in bed and just hear
everybody all my constantly because you
get sick immediately so you just start
to wash your hands all the time I'd have
to have to sleep with a towel wrapped
around your head cuz people are
screaming all the time and yelling Jim
it's ridiculous
yeah what do you want a laser printer
[Laughter]